who is she just me how many was first
I'll be no no you know your life is
different now you see the total of this
video it's time for an August favorites
let's jump right into some of the things
that I've liked slightly more than other
things this month yay first yeah KFC KFC
KFC you start it off with a cleaning
product that's not a sign that I'm aging
but it matches my lipstick so these are
correct triple action dust white I'm
sure you guys have heard of like the
Clorox wipes that are like have the
cleaning the Clorox wipes that are wet
that you can like wipe down I use them
to clean everything in my house but then
I found these dust wipes and life has
gotten even easier and lazier and better
I'm a dirty dirty Pigpen human so I get
a lot of dust in my house sometimes and
when I try using Clorox wipes it just
makes wet dust it feel like dryer sheets
and you can just they just get up all
the dust and then it's just on there
maybe these aren't just dryer sheets and
I'm being duped but advertising works
subscribe to our Channel yeah and you
can use these all over your electronics
too and it works wonderfully that's it
next hangout see you can you see it more
cleaning products what have I become
aware of my filth this is actually a
whole cleaning kit that came with like
these to spray this like chamois thing
and then like a travel chamois and it's
for cleaning your electronics cleaning
your computer screens and your phone
screens or your iPads or laptops or
whatever it's called I clear and clear
spell decay I got these on Amazon Prime
just kind of popped up as a recommended
thing and I was like yeah to be honest I
don't know if they're the best brand out
there but they work so I like them when
I get on planes and I open up my laptop
that's really when I come to terms with
the fact that I'm just a garbage pail
kid there's just dirty fingerprints all
over the screen everywhere and like
crumbs all in the keyboard I'd become
very so
conscious of others realizing my secret
bills and the kit comes with all these
little travel ones so you can put them
just in your bag to have later if you
are a person that is force or someone
plans ahead what's that like next yeah
can y'all see ya see ya this is the
candle oh the wax wasn't finished drying
I just became an everyday places cuz I
like this candle so much no one to use
it in this video and so the wax wasn't
finished drying and I just got it all
over myself
it's the candle I got from Target and
this is on sale for like 12 dollars
instead of 15 I guess it doesn't say
what the scent is I threw away the thing
that says the scent
it says burn is in sight keep away from
things that catch fire what great advice
oh man it's vine vine what I'm gonna
look it up by anybody vineyard Hill
Naturals it's not by me this is not
right all right well this candle smells
awesome it's like a sweet Musk next yeah
can't see you can you see you this is an
eyebrow thing from NYX NYX Cosmetics it
is a three in one brow pencil I like
finding new products for my eyebrows I
saw this at Target when I got the
mystery candle and I went for it because
I like things that are combined into one
thing and make it easier for you so this
end has this like brow gel there you go
and then this end has a filler in like
little nubby nub open this one and then
the other end here has a smaller little
nub enough for like fine little eyebrow
line I thought that was so cool so I
bought it and I liked it and now I'm
telling you next see can you say yeah
yeah say yeah yeah say it these are
candy Johnson's
new cosmetics that she did with Too
Faced and it's called I want candy I
went to her launch party the other night
and they gave us all of our products and
they're so awesome
I love them already I'm wearing a lot of
it right now I'm wearing this lip color
right now
which is called which sweet and sour I
put these kind of lipsticks in
favourites videos before because they
last forever they're melted matte the
long wear lipstick these all smell like
candy I'm pretty sure I can do I have on
her channel a big long video explaining
in more in depth about all the products
if you're interested but I will say
they're awesome there's this eyeshadow
palette look at how pretty all the
colors are and they smell they still so
sweet but be careful because if you get
you drunk you might you know I say can
they eat one of these this is more of a
public service announcement to myself
she's got this like face powder coming
out of pudding that smells amazing and
all the packaging is super cute and
Candy's just an awesome all around the
human being make sure if you were at all
interested in any of these products you
go over to her channel check out her
instructional video about all of them
Congrats candy and I wish you much
success lovely angel human pixie woman
next this is this is from a company
called serene house and I think this is
like a room diffuser my mom got it for
me for Christmas
good old grace finally check it out of
the box in August but better late than
never
this thing's really awesome mom thank
you you basically open it up oh my god
and then you fill this part with water
and then there's all these essential
oils that it comes with that one is
called uplifting one's called comforting
and one's called refreshing and you just
put a few drops of whichever one you
want into the water and then you put the
lid back on let me plug this thing give
you a demo oh you're gonna get a demo so
you put this on and then there's buttons
you can put on and then look
all this smoke comes out and it lights
up and it's looking crazy on camera but
it could it change colors and then it
infuses your room with these central
oils that are supposed to create
that's not what they advertise it's cool
and I like it so there's that serene
house is the brand I think my mom got it
from Kohl's
something like that thanks mom okay
that's it for this favorites video let
me know what you guys been enjoying the
most this month and make sure you click
Subscribe to make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday except sometimes
not those I don't know
Oh comforting okay